yes it's that time again I'm back for
part three of shock Tober 2018 it's
about time you start carving your
jack-o'-lanterns and decorating the
house but first you'll stay here and
listen to me talk about spooky things
for another ten minutes last time we
spoke about the Abrahamic religions and
the concept of Satan and demons today
we'll be exploring ghosts and other ways
that evil and death has manifested
itself in a full klore I'll see you
after this very stupid intro
[Music]
[Music]
in the first episode I asked what it is
that we find so fascinating about death
and darkness as I've shown we've tackled
this question in many different ways
throughout our history and our different
cultures and this will be seen today as
well many of us love to watch horror
films it's some of the most successful
films in the box office these are films
that deal with ghosts demons and the
afterlife we seem to be drawn to the
dark and the McCobb at least some of us
appear to be very interested in these
things and perhaps this says something
about our human nature we will all die
someday this is a fact that's impossible
to avoid and it's always there at the
back of our minds and as a part of our
consciousness this idea that we are
mortal beings and to some people this is
the most frightening thing in the world
it's very common to be anxious about
death and I think I would argue on some
level we all are but on differing levels
the probably earliest known great piece
of literature is called the epic of
gilgamesh it comes from Mesopotamia and
was written around 2000 BC and one of
the main aspects of its story deals with
the character Gilgamesh and his quest to
find the secret to eternal life
so clearly this was on the minds of
people 4,000 years ago as well in any
case our culture since then has been
crawling with stories about death and
the monsters that are related to it from
demons to zombies vampires and of course
regular old ghosts the definition of
what a ghost is is of course pretty hard
to pin down and I don't think we should
get caught up in linguistics in this
video so we'll just consider ghosts to
be you know ghosts we all know what
ghosts is is it's the it's the spirit of
a dead person that comes back and haunts
the living this of course directly
relates to our ideas about the ass
life if ghosts are indeed real then
there must be an afterlife and if you
believe in ghosts then on some level at
least you must believe in a life after
this one
ghosts are sometimes evil and sometimes
not the most important part is that
they're dead and that there's still
somehow around and let's be honest in
almost every case they are evil or at
the very least scary Japan is famous for
its horror films that were especially
popular around the turn of the 21st
century and these include films like the
ring and you on The Grudge and and and
many more but stories like these aren't
new to Japanese culture in fact Japan
has a very long history of telling ghost
stories called Cayden and many of these
films are taken directly or at least
inspired by many of these storytelling
traditions much like our European
conception of ghosts the Japanese
equivalent which is often called au ray
and please excuse all pronunciations
from now on is the spirit of a dead
person that has been kept from a
peaceful afterlife
they are stuck in a kind of purgatory in
between our world and the next and is
thus able to haunt the living the
funeral is very important for the
well-being of a spirit after death and
the way in which the person died also
plays a major role if everything goes
well including the funeral then the
spirit can move on to the afterlife and
and sort of be at peace however if the
person died in a very violent way like
if he was or she was murdered or
committed suicide then something else
happens the spirit will then often
become a you day a kind of ghost driven
by emotions of hatred and revenge as a
result of the way in which they died
they can then enter our world and enact
that revenge on the person who killed
them or just on anyone that happens to
come in their way which is actually
often the case in these stories for
those of you who have seen some of these
Japanese horror films these themes will
seem very familiar
to you in the ring for example the ghost
of a dead girl who was murdered by being
tossed into a well haunts and kills
anyone who watches a specific videotape
the way in which she died made her a
vengeful spirit that seeks to enact
revenge on the living
similarly in jus on The Grudge the ghost
of a mother and her child who were
brutally murdered in their house haunts
anyone who enters said house they are
both very frightening and dark stories
that take heavy inspiration from the
traditional ghost stories of Japan in
many of these cases the spirit or ghost
can be freed or released by helping it
achieve its purpose by for example
enacting revenge on those who kill them
but in many cases even this doesn't help
another significant and interesting
detail is the appearance in old
theatrical performances of ghost stories
in Japan the ghost or Ouray were
eventually given a very characteristic
look to emphasize that they were ghosts
one they always had long unkept black
hair and two they were often dressed in
white sort of funeral or burial clothing
again we can here see clear influences
on modern Japanese horror films the
image of a woman dressed in white with
long black hair has become
characteristic of that kind of film in
one of the more famous quedan or ghost
stories from Japanese tradition called
the dish mansion at Bonn show it tells
of a servant girl called o'kiku who
works for a samurai the samurai falls in
love with her and at multiple location
makes advances towards her but she
always refuses he thing comes up with a
plan and makes it seem like the servant
has lost one of the family's priceless
plates she desperately tries to find it
as the punishment for such a crime would
normally be death
the samurai then offers to pardon her on
the terms that she would become his
lover but she refuses once again and the
samurai become so angry that he throws
her down a well killing her as a result
of this terrible death the ghost of the
servant comes back to haunt the samurai
every now and then letting out a
terrible scream it becomes so bad that
the samurai has to seek help to ridden
of this terrible situation at the very
other side of the world at least if you
follow this flat map in Mexico there's a
very interesting festival or celebration
that is strongly associated with death
this is the holiday of known as Day of
the Dead the origin of this festival is
contested with some scholars arguing
that it has origins in Aztec culture but
during this holiday which is celebrated
for several days friends and family
gathered to remember and honor those who
have died often visiting graves with
gifts of food or other objects it bears
some similarity to the Christian holiday
of All Saints Day that is celebrated in
many other parts of the world this is a
time when people consciously come into
contact with death by remembering those
who have passed away and also indirectly
reminding oneself of our own mortality
it is said that the Day of the Dead is a
very happy and festive occasion and thus
it can function as a way of approaching
death in a celebratory fashion
likewise here in Europe we have a lot of
ghost stories as well often including
haunted houses or objects but if we move
away for a second from the traditional
ghost we can start exploring another
creature from northern European and
Scandinavian folklore one of the most
prominent characters you'll find here is
known as the mayor the mayor is an evil
being that visits people at nights there
are many stories told throughout
Scandinavia Germany and the Slavic world
the tales of the mayor terrorizing
people as they sleep
the mayor doesn't have a particular form
but it is a being that can take on many
different forms like animals it can look
like a horse like a cat or just simply
as a dark mass but perhaps the most
common way of perceiving the mayor
through these stories that are told is
as a woman what is peculiar about this
legend is that people often experience
the mayor as sitting on their chest
which creates a great feeling of anxiety
and often trouble of breathing and I
know a lot of you are thinking about
sleep paralysis right now and that's a
very interesting point during sleep
paralysis people often tell how they
experience these being standing above
them or in many cases creatures sitting
on their chest in folklore from this
region of the world sleep paralysis
among other things are probably
conceptualized into the mare giving it a
mythological expression furthermore the
mare is thought to be the cause of
nightmares so she could be haunting you
without you even knowing it and this
connection between nightmares and this
legend can be clearly heard in the name
itself night mare and this is pretty
universal to European languages for
example in Swedish the mare is known as
Mara and the word for nightmare is
mordrem which literally translates to
mare dream I was in an archive in a
museum not long ago when I was looking
at old sort of documents and letters
from a region in Sweden where I grew up
partly and I discovered there that a lot
of these documents talk about sightings
of the mare and these were only about a
hundred years old so even though most
people don't talk or think about the
mayor it still lingers in our culture
and remain as part of our history and so
perhaps she is still out there somewhere
and maybe standing over your bed tonight
as you sleep speaking of which I
recently heard a ghost story that runs
within my own family this takes place
around the turn of the last century and
in a part in Western Sweden where I
we grew up it was a winter's day and my
great-great grandfather or something
like that was on his way home from work
but as he was walking along one of the
roads he saw his wife out in the field
and she was jumping around in a strange
way from left to right and he was very
confused I thought this was strange so
he called out to her but she wouldn't
answer him she just kept jumping and
eventually she disappeared behind the
treeline and he of course still thought
this was very strange but he kind of
shook it off and kept walking home and
as he came home he told his friends and
family who were there what he had seen
that he had seen his wife jumping around
in this field and he asked them if they
knew what she was doing why didn't why
she was out there and the people there
were shocked and they told him don't you
know your wife died earlier today in a
drowning accident ghost stories like
these are apparent all over folklore all
around the world there is something
about our fascination with death and the
afterlife that compels us to wonder and
sometimes shiver at the possibilities
this theme will be continued in the next
episode when I'll be talking about the
long-awaited holiday of Halloween as
well as some of our most beloved pop
culture monsters I'll see you then